did you decide what we're watching for  movie night no it's like there's nothing  good on Netflix anymore  hi I'm from the Census why did you do  that a guy wanting a list of Latinos in  my house no thanks the census is  important for communities of color we  have to participate it determines  congressional seats and federal funding  and Latinos are all ha there's one I'd  rather be murdered opens oh hi sorry  about the whole door in your face thing  okay yeah that worse I've been bit by a  toddler tased by a grandma 2010 I was  insulted by a racist parrot anyway my  name is Brian and this is only gonna  take a few minutes so your your Penelope  Alvarez yes I am and I am the mother of  Elena and Alex oh okay that's good and  this is your husband Oh  [Laughter]  so you're single no husband no same-sex  partner no unmarried partner no same-sex  unmarried partner and now we know all  the different ways I'm single I'm very  happy check that off there's no box for  happy  [Music]